Aaron Schock was once a rising star in
the Republican Party I served with him
in Congress elected when he was just 27
years old he took on an almost celebrity
status even appearing on the cover of
Men's Health something I could never do
but six years ago in his timing after
six years of his time in Congress there
were allegations of misdeeds regarding
the decoration of his office and the
potential misuse of a campaign vehicle
according to his attorney 30 federal
agents were involved there were two
grand juries convened he was charged
with 24 felonies
two of which have been dismissed and he
faces 80 to a hundred years in prison
yet four years later the prosecutor was
reassigned after lying to the court he
says they have he has spent nearly three
million dollars defending himself and
yet he has still never had his day in
court it's time to hear Aaron's side of
the story and he joins me here today
Aaron tell me why are we at this
situation four years after the fact that
you left Congress well thank you for
having me on yes Jason as you know any
time you're involved in a legal matter
your attorneys say hey don't say
anything and and justice will prevail
and I've always believed in our criminal
justice system that they're interested
in the truth but sadly it became very
clear that over the two years that they
were investigating me that they were on
a massive fishing expedition they went
so far while I was still in office the
Obama Justice Department to wire up a
low-level staffer in my office they
directed that staffer without a search
warrant to steal documents in my office
to steal attorney-client privilege
material and to even steal records of
the House of Representatives and then
they were forced in court to admit they
didn't find anything so of course the
natural question okay so let me put this
graphic one of the things that catches
my attention here is that the House
Counsel is there to protect the
institution not necessarily the members
of Congress but I want to put up on the
screen what he actually has has said in
this this is the House Counsel talking
about the FBI in the Department of
Justice justice such conduct likely
constitutes a federal crime on the part
of the FBI on the part of federal agents
who induce the commission of that
lying crime so he's taken the position
not against Aaron Schock but in support
of Aaron Schock supported me into your
point the support of the institution of
the House of Representatives the
government has repeatedly infringed on
the separation of powers of the
institution of Congress and
unfortunately that letter has never been
responded to by the Justice Department
they have fringed upon the
constitutional rights of Congress as
well to make and interpret its own rules
and in the way they've charged me in
these supposed felonies is almost
laughable when you understand them let
me give you two quick examples one I
purchased a car with campaign funds
which is perfectly legal for for the use
of driving around my district we
submitted to the FEC the purchase of
that vehicle and the payment to the
dealership as a transportation expense
the government now has charged me with a
false statement to a federal agency they
believe it should have said transfer
division believe it should have said
vehicle purchase and they've charged as
opposed to transportation X 20 year
felony and as I recall they were turrent
the news or an article initially said oh
you had it run up you no more vehicle
miles than what you sold it for but
there were multiple vehicles involved
correct of course as you know when you
drive around your district you're not
always in the same vehicle at all times
and my staff and I were estimating my
mileage as we went around the district
which the house finance office accepted
as estimates ok local government now
comes back and says you can't have us
okay so let's go to your office one of
the criticisms is that you use this
extravagant amount of money to decorate
your office Downton Abbey was the thing
that was tagged in your office is that
what's your viewpoint on well first of
all it's not true the truth of matter is
Jason I've never seen the show Downton
Abbey I hadn't even heard of the show
Downton Abbey until the Washington Post
ran that story the next day I did an
interview with CBS Evening News where I
said this is not true the decorator who
did the office gave an interview to The
Huffington Post when he come from look
the money came from my budget my office
budget so I spent $25,000 from my office
budget on my office so members are given
what's called the members reimbursable
allowance it's roughly 1.4 million
dollars but you spent money
$25,000 or so of that office budget on
our your office exactly what were you
charged with this well so they're they
one of the items we purchase for example
the decorator purchase was a light
fixture and according to the house rules
you can buy fixtures but not furniture
and so the government has come in and
said well that's not a fixture that's a
piece of furniture again a false
statement of federal agency 20-year
felony so you're facing twenty years
because they say that you put it on your
form saying it was a fixture as opposed
to a piece of furniture even though it's
a piece of lighting correct I mean
that's really and you're facing twenty
years against that now why is this taken
so long I mean you have I've seen
multiple different prosecutors I believe
you're now on your third judge correct
so typically the Justice Department
miners this is my first rodeo my first
time dealing with this you typically the
Justice Department defers to local US
Attorney's office they get to run their
little fiefdom and they defer to their
judgment what's happened over the past
four years is the local US Attorney's
office this Obama holdover Justice
Department in central Illinois has
proven a lack of judgment frankly first
not only did they they they wire up my
informant illegally and steal documents
of mine so that doesn't happen with the
Department of Justice in Washington do
you know this is a local office who saw
me as a rising star in the Republican
Party and their ticket to stardom their
ticket to to move up the ladder within
the Justice Department after they wired
up my format and didn't find anything
they then during the grand jury process
I used my Fifth Amendment right to not
appear against me and when we heard
about it we called them out on it to the
judge the judge asked the prosecutor's
office were you doing this they
emphatically denied it three months
later they had to admit to the court
they had lied and in fact they had used
my Fifth Amendment against me 11 times
on eleven different occasions and yet
the case continues to move forward and
finally just a couple weeks ago we found
out that the same US Attorney's Office
was engaged in ex parte communication
with the judge in my case about another
criminal matter and that's why we've now
got a new judge do you think you you
were charged two days after Donald Trump
was elected to you right that's a
coincidence no I believe this look this
US Attorney we
no contacted members of Congress
advocating for help becoming the next US
Attorney because again he was the guy
who was prosecuting Aaron Schock we know
that he was a finalist as one of the
finalists for the case I've got about 15
seconds the case you now have paperwork
with the Supreme Court what are the
possibilities there well we hope the
supreme court accepts our hearing
because there's important constitutional
concerns about allowing the Justice
Department to reinterpret the house of
the house rules which are the the
theorem of the house thank you very much
for being here and explaining a lot more
to this case